so this was super unexpected but I just
played Magnus Carlson in the Mr dodgy
Invitational I was unexpected for a few
reasons first of all I caught a last
minute invite yesterday they needed a
filler player and uh I was lucky enough
to be contacted I was the lowest rated
player out of the whole field
and on top of that
um there is a last minute drop out of
David Howell and the player to replace
him was Magnus Carlson so I ended up
playing Magnus in this video I'm going
to share my commentary of that game it
was super intense he played a crazy
opening and uh it did come down to the
very end I don't want to spoil things
too much beyond that and I will be
posting the full tournament video
shortly do subscribe if you want to see
that one I didn't livestream it on
Twitch but I pre-recorded and I will uh
be editing that and posting it very soon
so stay tuned and enjoy the chess I'm
probably not going to talk too much of
this game
if he plays E4 I'm so tempted to go into
Staffing habit I think I'll play
Sicilian now
E3 okay
I saw his matching as Ray Robinson
um
I also just plays Vincent climber
G4 bomb
um
I'm supposed to
oh my gosh
thank you
it's H6
I'm just losing a pawn
man
I don't think it's so bad though
take take
foreign
okay let's keep Wings on the board
only down the pond
against Magnus
oh I really mishandled the opening
like
maybe Castle kingside even
Council Queensland
and there's some camp
got a file
foreign
peace out
foreign
G5 is the plan
hmm
Bishop B3
foreign
foreign
have to take
foreign
foreign
take
Bishop takes Rook C7
um
foreign
okay how do I resign
I wonder I wonder if I had chances there
oh C5 move
and I played it without fully
calculating a king G1 what to do
that's an interesting game I felt like I
was gonna get smashed in the opening
and then
I was surviving
I wonder if C6 was a better option
but C6 is Bishop Bishop King B7 uh C6 G6
though
yeah maybe I'm just like in a lot of
trouble
I mean I also had rug off seven
[Music]
oh tricky position good game though a
Magnus is good the chess